all right we're gonna jump to this first
story and it's from the new york times
but we will be leading with a quote from
dan price posting on linkedin he said
in the unlikely event that you are
falsely accused remember that will be
much easier for you to overcome false
allegations than it will be for actual
victims to overcome the trauma of
harassment or assault go on uh that
being said dan
i suppose i'm not supposed to care at
all that you are claiming these are
false allegations but these are some
crazy allegations so take a look at the
headline social media was a ceo's
bullhorn and how he lured women
this is what you get when you pander to
woke people or maybe the people who
pander to these woke people are just
predators
dan price was applauded for paying a
minimum salary of seventy thousand
dollars at a seattle company and
criticizing corporate greed the
adulation helped to hide and enable his
behavior
i'm just gonna give you the gist of it
yo this is crazy like they talk about
how he's on the daily show and they did
magazines with him but apparently he's
been accused um
i guess of like drugging a woman look at
this raping and drug drugging a victim
on monday police in palm springs
california said they had referred ms
marges's case to local prosecutors
recommending a charge of rape of a
drugged victim
prosecutors in seattle earlier this year
charged with a price with assault and
another incident apparently tried to
kiss a woman and then when she refused
he choked her
so questions
is this retaliation from the woke
because you can never trust them or is
it that if someone is willing to pander
and lie to gain power they're probably
willing to do that for sex
yeah and there's there's sort of a
a default like the the fakeness of nice
like i actually distinguish between
being nice and being kind
right like kindness is something that
comes from a position of like strength
and normalcy nice whenever you talk
about nice guys you always know that
there's like an element of like
deception nefariousness right like it's
sort of like i think that people think
that they put coins in the nice it's
like a like a vending machine right they
put coins in a nice button and then
eventually they get to the girl they
want like a nice guy won't step on
someone's toes a kind guy might step on
your toes just to let you know your toes
are in the wrong spot yeah or like what
kind of does it for kind of just does it
from a position of strength right like
they have the ability to do they could
be they have powers so but they're being
kind not using it that way we're as nice
as like
they're like they're trying to attract
women by being
like fake and they're like they think
it's a game yeah
i knew i knew a guy
me and my me me and this other guy we
were hanging out my one friend is like
you know a rico suave type who's going
to bars and picking up chicks and like
very proud of himself and this other guy
was having trouble
so i'm sitting there and i'm kind of
like passively listening
and this we'll call him guy a because i
don't want to
call anybody's personal lives out but
guy a is talking about how he doesn't
understand why he's always in the friend
zone he goes on to so so you know guy b
who's this suave dude is like tell me
what you do when you go on a date and he
explained how he he's like i always put
women i always treat them like royalty
like queens i ask them whatever they
want you can have
and then
we i i'm listening to this and i was
just like dude you think that comes off
as sincere and nice
like you're treating the person like
they're not really there with you you're
acting like they're a piece of plastic
and that you're going to feed the
machine quarters hoping that sex comes
out i was like that's not what being
like that's not nice that's creepy yeah
and also breeds resentment right like
then they feel because they have put in
the nice coins and they don't get what
they're expecting they get super
resentful and angry about it it's like
the kind of guy who there's like a woman
and she's got spinach in her teeth and
he's like i'm not gonna say that's
exactly what i was thinking about the
hottest girl in the world if she got
spinach her teeth tell her she she wants
to know this so she can take it out
right but that's anybody too like nice
and kind it's like if someone had gunk
in their teeth would you tell them i do
yeah i'm like hey you got a thing in
your teeth yeah and i go oh thanks
they'll be more mad at you if you didn't
tell them right and then they find out
they're like why didn't they tell me
cause like i don't want to put you on
the spot i don't want to no so so this
guy dan price i really want to talk
about his business because
so much of what we see coming from
perceive this really really grinds my
gears the idea of left versus right if
you are a sincere person who asks a
question you're right-wing
i'll give you i'll give you i'll give
you an example right
uh sheamus this is one of sheamus jokes
he says
the left will come out and be like we
want good thing we want good thing and
then a conservative will go
okay how should how do we pay for a good
thing you want bad thing you want bad
thing
and that's like the whole it's like your
right wing for simply being like
so we get the story of this guy dan
price he raises everybody's salary well
i happen to run a company and i
understand how taxes work so my first
question here
he lowers his salary from like a million
bucks or something to seventy thousand
and for me alarm bells went off i was
like oh bro is trying to save himself
some money because it's it's when when
uh when you take profit versus uh
like compensation it's their tax
differently and so or this is at least
how two of my two different accounting
companies i've gone with have explained
it to me so
you know maybe they're not correct but
this is my understanding is that passive
profit is not taxed the same way as
employment income or compensate direct
compensation so when i see this i'm like
if the dude lowers his salary he's going
to save a lot of money in taxes right
that's assuming if he owns or has a
major stake in the company right he's
running right and i'm pretty sure this
dude does this yeah he does right yeah
he gets profit
so at the end of the year if you're only
paying yourself 70k like bezos does this
bezos takes an 87 000 a year salary and
then gets bonuses
and then
justify the irs why your salary is so
low but if you're going to get audited
anyway so what i was told by uh two
different accounting companies was if
you're a ceo of a company with you know
like an eight-figure revenue and then
you pay yourself something like 70k yo
you're gonna get audited in two seconds
because they're like that's that's bolt
that's bull you're trying to not pay
your employment taxes
so when i saw this i was like well how
would how would you get around that it's
ideological now if they come to you and
be like hey man that's not it at all i
believe in fair wages for all people and
i shouldn't be making that much money in
a salary
but in profits a different question
right so i don't know if how much money
he actually saved by doing it he did
raise the salaries of everybody in his
company became a big star over it
surprise surprise the dude's being
accused
again i think there's a strong
possibility it's false accusation i'm
not i'm not going to assume it's these
are real claims just because the guy
happens to be on the left yeah all the
raises he made are kind of goes back to
what will is saying about kind versus
nice because the raises could have just
been the veneer of nice of kindness
right but it's really just a nefarious
niceness right and now it's blowing up
in his face i feel like that's so much
of what the left is i mean i think this
is what most people kind of feel
that it's performative grifting
you know
maybe he did something good it's like
all right you know yeah but what was
like and and and i have to say this
about trump too
is the reasoning behind it that
important if they're actively doing
something good
because we have to speculate as to his
reasoning but i think it's great that
he's paying his staff more money
i got an article from geekwire about
this story he made according to you know
whatever the documents that he made 950
000 in
2010 900 000 in 2011 but then when he
went on tv told him he made 50 000 in
2011 when he actually made 900 000.
uh this was on
january and then this was uh with cnbc
kelly evans is when he told her i made
probably fifty thousand then he later
came out was like oh i misspoke
so i don't know if this guy's a hundred
thousand dollars he's just he's just a
creep he's like he's a classic male
feminist right like literally arc tipple
male feminist you know using
uh like woke politics and like bs
because he thinks that's what women want
to hear and then when they say no
all of a sudden the fangs come out dude
he if he actually made 900 000 and told
someone that he made 50 000 that's
insanity he's a psychotic person like
is he misleading he's like my salary was
only but he knows in the back of his
mind he made 900 000 in profit
uh it's really disturbing that he made
that and he was like let this be the
last lie i ever tell apparently
apparently there was a guy for me
apparently there were big problems when
he did this too
so like what happened was these are just
stories that i heard there were some
employees that were making 70k a year
because they were like an accounts
manager and then there are some people
who are in the mail room who are getting
hourly pay all of a sudden these mail
room people got bumped up to the same
salaries and accounts manager who saw no
raise
and then they were just like i've been
here for how long and you gave them a 50
000 a year raising i got nothing
and so i i read you know it's been a
long time it could be wrong but a bunch
of people resigned saying like it's
deeply offensive that we would not
receive more compensation
but like the idea of a minimum wage
meant they got nothing and the people of
lower skill and lower time at the
company lower seniority got massive like
two or three hundred percent raises yeah
i would actually be furious right like
it's like a complete stunt if you're one
of those people making like 70 80k for a
job that you know requires a college
degree and you have debts and things
like that and then he like bumps up like
the the you know intern or whatever the
entry-level job up to 70 and you're like
where's my race the argument was
supposed to be that's like you shouldn't
be mad that someone else is making more
money that's what a lot the left was
saying like what it's not affecting you
at all and it's like you got to
understand man
when your company
takes money from the budget and gives a
raise to everyone but you
that is like getting punched in the gut
that's crazy and so the idea but it's
raised to a minimum it's like yeah but
like to hear that a co-worker got a 500
or 300 raise and you got a zero it's not
about 70k it's not about a minimum it's
about you working hard and hoping to
make more money to live a better life
and he's not doing that for you
but everybody else you are now it's
almost like they got pushed to the
minimum so people resigned you know
apparently but hey look man i i don't
care how he runs his business you know
he can do whatever he wants
congratulations he found a way to get a
bunch of attention make a bunch of money
yeah don't be a predator though that
seemed pretty yeah you know it's a good
takeaway yeah maybe maybe definitely i
object first and foremost to the
predation
right it's like
like it's here here it's like that nor
mcdonald joke it's like you know the
worst thing about bill cos somebody's
like saying the worst thing about bill
cosby is hypocrisy and he's like no i
thought the worst thing about bill cosby
was you know the crimes
yeah
yeah that's a thing man so
you know when i look at what there's a
guy in here seven years running the
marketing company that's the main
company
well this guy right this guy wait i
don't know this yeah they're both
they're both dudes okay it's a new man
yeah so like when i see people like uh
dan price i i'm actually kind of like
okay you know like do you think man like
i'm not gonna complain about a guy how
he runs his business if he's getting
attention for raising salaries it's like
whatever dude i don't trust it but i'm
not here to rag on that you know what i
mean if somebody wants to
do their business that way it's
far be it for me you know but the
surprise surprise you know i mean like
drug raping a drugged victim is a crazy
thing to be accused of yeah now i'll say
this too innocent until proven guilty
always because i i think i think it
could be false i mean look
you're a powerful white man
and you enter the woke fray to exploit
it i wonder if some of this stuff is
they know he's grifting off them so they
destroy him you know like not just his
story but other stories where they're
like
as a possibility it also may just be
dude imagine being like made of
cheese
and then deciding to walk into a room
full of mice you know what i mean like
like imagine being a banana and walking
to a monkey sanctuary look i'm just
going to go with his advice i don't want
to inflict trauma on his victims
i'm just going to i'm just going to
believe his accuser
and leave it at that that's such a sense
of hubris to be like i got this i'll be
fine i'm a white guy but i can i got
this in my bag as long as i pander to
them i'll be safe here
they should know though that so many
heroes that they prop up they eventually
it's like the new hero's journey they
end up falling they end up devouring
themselves in the end whether they did
it or not it's like yeah you know louis
c.k was one of them and a lot of people
whether it was true or not who i i can't
it's crazy
you know so we use parallel economy for
tim cast and this is co-founded by dan
bongino it's censorship resistance why
would i
use a company that hates me it's like
you're the ceo of this company and
you're like i know let's pan to the
people who explicitly hate me based on
my race and my gender and that's a good
business move that seems like really
dumb it seems yeah very fragile based in
fear yeah yeah that's what i think
desperation tactic if you were to do
something like that that'd be like using
your slave owners weapons to break out
of slavery or something right i don't
know but they only do that because
that's their only option if you have
another option
you use the company that you thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there